one of my favorite films is Chris
Nolan's you will be inception and it's
all about the workings of the mind the
world and dreams and imagination and
there's a key motif that recurs
throughout the film and that's the power
of love to fill you to envelop you in
feelings of grace and faith and safety
like this cosmic safeties
intersubjective safety that you
experience when you create a universe
with another person and there's a line
I'm going to paraphrase it from the film
that really sums up this feeling and it
goes like this you're waiting for a
train you don't know where this train
will take you but it doesn't matter
because you'll be together and of course
the context being that when you find
that person in whose eyes you feel
reflected and you feel enveloped about
it
that you enter the forever box you enter
a holy space a space where you are
rendered whole and you are rendered
wholly together and this space the space
of the God the space of Adam and Eve
outside of time outside of mind outside
of fear and outside of yes life no
longer has uncertainty life no longer
had potential dangers you don't care
where this train is going you don't know
where this train of life will take you
because of no longer matters because
you'll be together as you can see why
this line is so captivating to me
because I've known this kind of love
I've tasted this kind of rapture and
Rhapsody right I've stared into the iris
of a lovers eye I've cried as she cries
we've shared an experience of being
moved together we've both been absolved
from our contradictions we've
experienced this rapture in Rhapsody and
I know for a fact that this is exactly
what the film meant in
this line it's like you no longer worry
about the future because you are now
into the forever box with this person
holding hand in the Garden of Eden and
my god is that an intoxicating
experience to fall out of that love is
to be burned right breakups are death
practice you fall into the void
how do you recover from them and how do
you get over that mmm that burning in
the belly that anxiety that trauma that
is so afraid of experiencing that death
practice again and again and again every
time you look at a pretty girl walking
down the street and so this is my
ongoing unfolding this is my journey
this is my my yearning is to find that
person again and to be absolved from my
fears and to say to myself I don't know
where this train will take me but it
doesn't matter because we'll be together
[Music]